jackpot
a gift from my anonymous sponsors thanks
I hardly endorse your product and/or
service let's see what survival
equipment did for me
waterproof MRE worthless Oh first date
equipment worthless combat tomahawk
worthless hahaha the anime encyclopedia
score I know a lot of people say that
The Hunger Games franchise is just a
watered-down why a version of the
brilliant Japanese movie Battle Royale
well I completely disagree Hunger Games
is actually a watered-down why a version
of the classic Schwarzenegger film
Running Man but my real beef with the
Hunger Games is that I don't buy the
premise I'm supposed to believe that
everyone in this future society are
continually glued to their TV sets by
this contest no chance
it's a terrible live show I can overlook
the fact that capturing the action as
its portrayed in the film would be
impossible as it would require tens of
millions of carefully concealed cameras
but look the hunger games begin with a
chaotic flurry of action in which a
third of the contestants die we don't
have time to invest in any of them I
assume that the societal collapse that
led to this dystopia also destroyed all
episodes of Survivor because the
showrunner of this Hunger Game Show
doesn't understand how to pace a
competition reality show after that
initial chaos we settle in for weeks and
weeks of this
no killing or dying just this and then
for a change more of this live
round-the-clock footage of hiding and
maybe building fortifications and
conserving rations so they don't slowly
perish from malnutrition I don't care
how star for entertainment these future
people are they're not going to spend
days watching children build tree forts
and forage for edible lichens and every
once in a while getting murdered The
Hunger Games would be much more exciting
and dramatic if the kids were forced to
answer trivia questions every two hours
you what planet is Sinestro from wrong
bang
how would you tweak the rules of The
Hunger Games
let me know in the comments do you think
I'm being unfair to the show tell me why
in the comments